foreign
thank you
assalamualaikum welcome back to the
realest podcast in the Dunya the three
Muslims we're joined here with brother
Michael from Tick Tock from Islam talk
can you hear me bro
hey we can't hear you brother yeah we
can't hear you bro
you might be having some audio issues
tell him to to disconnect and reconnect
again yeah let me do that bro
see
oh okay yeah
foreign
but how are you two doing today
beautiful Brothers
sit down to everyone
shouldn't the Live start now
bro shouldn't you changes
what's going on what's going on with you
guys
uh man not much same old same old
okay
it's it's like that now already bro yeah
it's filling in for you eh yeah
[Music]
Mr Monroe I had a dream about Army he
was in there only a couple of seconds
love what
yeah
Andrew Tay became a Muslim again
nothing's guaranteed boys
you guys are all here just on the edge
bro like we're gonna make a response
very soon inshallah stay tuned for
tomorrow brother Michael
here we go
sounds good okay cool now without
further Ado we want to thank you for
your time and uh we want to get straight
into it we want to jump into it go into
your story
um just roughly you know the few words
that we've exchanged thus far you
mentioned that you know you came to
Islam in 2006 right but I'm sure it's
not just like one day you just woke up
and you became Muslim so how was your
story
it's a long story I I always you know I
was raised like most Americans seems
like nowadays very secular
um you know my dad maybe he would be
agnostic really he says he doesn't know
you know I mean he leans more towards
there's a Creator but doesn't really
worry about anything beyond that and my
mom is nominally a Christian so like
most Americans they're a Christian just
because that's what Americans are but he
didn't really go to church or anything
like that but my dad's parents they were
the most like devout church goers I knew
and so I used to go with them on Sundays
like I would go without my parents uh
because I felt this need to know God you
know I felt like I need to know my
Creator I I want to know what I'm
supposed to do in my life
um so I was going with them even as a
kid
um and also my mom's mom I'm very close
to her my parents had me they were 20.
they were still young who wouldn't hang
out and so they would drop me with my
mama's Mama all the time like I spent
all the weekends with her and she used
to always love like the old religious
movies like been her and especially the
Ten Commandments and as a kid I used to
love watching think of Emma's weather I
used to love that story of Musa Moses
um and so
I was always like
interested in this idea of who is God I
was interested in in prophets like with
Musa especially his story
and when I got to be about like
13 I was uh having a lot of questions
you know I was going to church with my
grandma you know watching those movies I
had been reading a lot uh like recently
that time about mythology
you know that's why I was reading about
like uh Zeus and having Hercules as his
son and and he's having all these you
know hero babies with human women and I
started to think like wait a minute uh
it sounds like what we're doing in
Christianity so I was like what makes
this a myth and Christianity not a myth
you know and so I I started to ask my
grandma because she's the most religious
person I knew I said let me ask her all
these questions like what's up with this
what's up with that you know what what
is the what does God want from us what
is what is up with the you know Jesus
being godsend what does that actually
mean and and she said you know I don't
know I I don't really worry about those
things uh she's like you could ask the
pastor
but you know that really kind of
bothered me because I said you know how
do you spend this much time you're in
the choir you go Wednesdays and Sundays
to church you're so involved and you
don't even have these like fundamental
questions like answered for you like how
do you go through life like that I was
very frustrated I'm like 13.
and so you know I said you know I'll
just get the Bible because it's supposed
to be from God so I'll just read that
and it should tell me everything I need
to know
and I told my grandmother I said hey do
you have a Bible I can have and she said
yeah well the church gives you one but
she's like really you need to talk to
the pastor don't read the Bible uh on
your own and I thought something's wrong
here like why shouldn't I just go be
able to get God's book
and read it on my own
so I didn't listen to her I just started
reading you know and uh I remember I
came like I started reading it and I'm
really liking some of the stories
there's some weird things in there that
don't seem to Vibe with the rest of the
theme you know you'd have like crazy
stories about like prophets doing these
major sins after they've been so good
and righteous and God has talked to them
and then they do something crazy at the
end of their life like Noah he's your
father like he would they have him
getting drugged after he's saved from
the destruction of all of his people
you're gonna go like do something like
that you know it didn't make sense
get saved from this huge disaster he
sees all these evil people destroyed and
then you know he gets I don't know drunk
and seduced or whatever and all these
horrible things about these prophets it
doesn't make sense
uh you know so that would bug me
but I do remember reading in the Book of
Genesis about Abraham
Ibrahim and I was reading about him and
I was thinking like this guy hasn't like
this is how we're supposed to be like
this is what a human being should be
living like
and I was so confused because I said I
don't see Christians doing this I don't
see anybody living like this this direct
connection to God and this this life of
obedience to God like I didn't see that
yeah we just go to church we sing songs
and read a story and the preacher tells
us some of his life story and then we go
about our way
you know and there's nothing permeating
our whole life you know it's just
something you do on a weekend and you go
back and just forget about God for the
rest of the day
and that bothered me and then also
subhanallah it was like you know Allah
is calling me you know they at about
that time the Malcolm X movie came out
with Denzel Washington
right and so I'm watching this movie and
he's arguing with the priests and
bringing up all these things that he has
a problem with and they don't know how
to answer him you know and and I'm
listening to this I'm like man he's
making sense the things he's saying
and then a e had this series also the
same year like spiralized this series
came out called Mysteries of the Bible
and they would go through things in the
Bible that don't make sense
and they would try to make some sense of
it or try to go through it and I
remember something really really
bothered me they go they were talking
about Saint Augustine and they say Saint
Augustine
made up this idea of original sin for
Christianity that you're born with this
sin and they said he did it because he
became a monk he devoted his life to
Christianity but he still had all these
desires so he said there must be
something fundamentally wrong with
people right so he came up with this
idea of original sin
and I said to myself I'm like 13 and I
said
this guy just gets to make up like
fundamental things of the religion I'm
like he's not God he's not a prophet
I can't accept this you know really
bothered me
you know so then I get older I kind of
you know start to kind of kind of move
on I said maybe you know something's
wrong here I kind of lost interest got
busy with high school life you know
and then when I turned 18
when you turn 18 you're about to finish
High School you start questioning life
you say what is my purpose or what am I
supposed to be doing
you know and I tried partying being bad
I tried being good all these things it's
like not not satisfying to your heart
and so I said maybe I need to really
give Christianity another try you know
because we have this default at least in
in America like it's Christianity or a
bust right so you're like I either got
to be a Christian
or I guess atheist or whatever you know
and I think that's why you get so many
atheists recently as people see the
problems with Christianity
and they said I guess it just must be
all fake right or they must all be wrong
so they just leave religion all together
and don't even give anything else a
chance
and so I tried really hard when I was
like 18 to be a Christian I got baptized
at 18 because
I was Methodist they make you choose to
be baptized they don't do it when you're
a baby like the Catholics or something
you know so you say I want to join this
Christianity I want to be I believe in
this I want to be part of it and when I
was going to be baptized they interview
you like why do you really want to do it
and I was so ready to do it you know
because I've been you know pumped up uh
and right before you know I do the
interview and something really bothered
me because the pastor calls me in and he
says explain what you understand about
Jesus his christology like what do you
see him as
and honestly I I didn't have a clear
picture
so I just kind of at the time I'm just
kind of making up putting what I think
Christianity teaches
and I got done and I'm thinking okay now
he's gonna correct me right he's gonna
tell me oh no no let me make it clear
for you he just said okay sounds good
I was like what like I didn't even have
a coherent like theology there it was
all a you know mystery and you know it
seemed like you know God has put in some
of his Essence into a human or whatever
and he just like went with it and and so
I went ahead and got baptized but you
know that stuck in my hand like
why am I telling you and you're like oh
that sounds good like you explained it
better than than I could have almost
so that bugged me uh you know but it's I
put it in the back of my mind you have
these struggles you're like let me put
it in the back of my mind
and so
I was going to church regularly and I
was trying to be into it I was reading
the Bible again heavily I'm still seeing
some discrepancies I'm studying history
and and I'm starting to see problems too
where you see more human influence on
Christianity specifically
um and then I got to college and in
college I started taking like
anthropology and in college even I went
College I started college in 2000. uh
not to date myself but uh
um they were pushing already these ideas
of like moral relativism in 2000 they're
teaching me like you know whatever
people feel is right is right uh your
feelings guide you to the truth you know
it's kind of this emotional criteria for
Truth Versus something concrete
something solid you know so that stuff
starts infecting you and I start looking
at Christiana I say you know I keep
seeing signs that it's man-made or so
tainted by human beings
and so I thought you know what's the
difference with me make it up my own
thing you know and and so I kind of uh
left it and I was thinking like
anthropology you know and they would we
would do anthropology of religion they
say oh religion is just something
humans make up to deal with the unknown
parts of life you know so it's just a
human creative thing or whatever and and
you know
I didn't become atheist because I had
enough of my fifthra and I had enough
connection to God because even when I
was younger I was always praying to God
I'm not praying to Jesus ever I never
thought I'd even get that from our
church even that you prayed to Jesus it
was only like pray to the father Our
Father Who Art in Heaven like Jesus
teaches you when he teaches you to pray
pray to God the father he doesn't say
pray to me pray to the Holy Spirit like
directly our father and it says our it's
like his and ours not just him
you know so
I always have that that you know only
your worship God but I just had so much
problem now I'm seeing Christianity as
something with human influence on it
that I just kind of became a deist you
know where I said I know there's a God
I don't know what that God was from us I
don't know if he's really communicated
to us or it's got lost in history or
what
um so I kind of just said I'll just be a
yes and I'll just kind of buffet My
Religion I'll pick whatever I like you
know
um and I I was into martial arts too and
so I did look at Eastern religions like
Buddhism and taoism but I never ever
looked at Islam
I also looked at Judaism because I liked
a lot of the theology I like the belief
in one God I like the belief in Prophets
but it was very ethnic center right you
got to be from the children of Israel
God only sent prophets to the children
of Israel
and I said that can't be the truth
because it has to be Universal right for
if it's from our creator all of us it's
got he's got to be trying to get all of
us on the guidance you know
and so yeah I was just frustrated I kind
of just wondered and then I met some
Muslims in college alhamdulillah
and they stood out to me because I was
not 21 at this time
you know at 21 all you do is you go to
the nightclub you get drunk every
weekend you're trying to get with as
many people of the opposite sex as you
can you know that's the 21 year old life
because you try to to live that social
life and I need these Muslims and
they're not interested in any of them
right alhamdulillah they were practicing
enough or they were you know they're
doing their Salat but we didn't know
because they didn't do it in front of us
and they were doing Ramadan
and uh when I'd hang out with them you
know uh and even like some of them you
know some of them were girls we try to
talk to them and they're like not
allowing us to date or we're not wanting
to go out and they're going to be home
by nine or whatever you're like what is
this like who does this anymore you know
so it really made me curious about what
makes them tick why are you different
from everybody else
so I start asking them you know
questions
and especially when Ramadan came because
they're Ramadan they started fasting you
know we used to eat less together with
the
student rec center or whatever and
all of a sudden they don't eat anymore
and you know you're like what's going on
they're like well we don't eat for 30
days or drink
and I was like y'all are crazy you're
gonna kill yourself like what is this
you can't eat for a month like what kind
of religion is this they say no we eat
at night you know but during the day we
fast forgot so why do you do that and
they said well this is how we show God
that we're we love him this is how we
show Devotion to God
and I was like wow I said now that
that's how you worship God I said you
know you can't give God anything God
doesn't need anything from us even I
knew that from my fifth one
and I said but you could give up
something from yourself as a
demonstration of Devotion to God so when
they did that fasting they talked to me
what they knew about it explained it I
was like this this something to this
but I didn't know nothing about Islam
you know
at that time I thought Islam was like
Arabian mythology I thought it was like
Aladdin and Sinbad and that was what
Islam was you know that's all we do they
don't teach us about Islam you know when
when I was in high school we do world
history we do Egypt the Greeks the
Romans we skip a thousand years don't
say nothing
and then we do Columbus finds the new
world and I'm like
what happened that thousand years like
what's going on where you know what
happened with Islam you know came out
you know so
um so I I was really curious whenever I
was in anthropology I was kind of
majoring in that when I had a project a
research project I picked Islam every
time after that because the Muslims made
me so curious
so I would do research on food taboos I
would do research on gender relations
and all of these things I'm picking
Islam every time to study it and I kept
reading stuff and I kept like it's
making sense to me I like it you know I
and I see parallels in the Bible
and so
the like the about a year went by you
know and then the next you know I had to
go a project I had to go to the mosque
like they said go to a non-Christian
religious service as your research
project so I said I'll look to the
mosque because I'm so curious all right
so I go to the moscure in in town
and uh I I came there like on a Friday
afternoon after Jeremiah was like
dismissal for the kids it was chaotic
they were crazy I don't know what's
going on I'm nervous I don't know what
the rules are you know and uh I go ask
them I said do you guys have any event I
can attend and they said well you just
missed you I bet tomorrow night we have
a dinner for somebody and then they were
going to feed the community the family
they said come to that dinner so I came
to the dinner
and I walked in and I loved it I saw all
this diversity like so many different
cultures and they're all sitting
together
and when I sat down I sat between
um a guy that was like middle-aged
Pakistani and a guy that was like a
teenager and he was from I think he's
Palestinian but he's from Jordan
right and I was like how is this so much
diversity both in the same thing the
same religion you know so I was asking
them questions and they I would say what
do you guys believe about God they tell
me I take notes and I was thinking in my
mind like I agree with this like this is
a good concept of God he's absolutely
one he's not like the creation you know
I would even laugh sometimes I saw yeah
I said other religions they make him
like a big old man in the clouds you
know and the way they talk about him and
I said this is beautiful and then you
know then I try to play cool and then I
they tell me I said well you guys
believe about Jesus they tell me one one
other guy jumped in he was like you know
Jesus from Palestine like me he looked
like me probably not those white guys
they put in the painting you know and I
said yeah you know they're laughing you
know taking notes and and then uh
I asked about what they believe about
the devil you know because the way the
devil's portrayed in the Bible is like
or actually in Christianity more it's
like he's the king of hell and he's
trying to get as many people away from
God and it's like this rivalry between
God and the devil and Islam it's like no
God is in total control there is no
rivalry nobody can rival God just
shaytan is here to try to you know
because of his bitterness and his Envy
he wants to get us all to follow him to
Hellfire and I said that makes a lot
more sense God nobody can even go
against God I mean there's no no
competition there
so and then they got up to make Salah
and I had never seen Muslims do Salah
really in person
and they got up to mix Allah and they
all got it and they were at that place
at that time they hadn't finished the
Masala they only had the gym so they get
out these rugs and they go and they pray
and I sit there and I'm watching them
and I'm like now this this is how you
worship your creator like they're bowing
down they're frustrating
like you know
you know at church we would you know
sing and then we would sit and listen to
somebody like and we would make dollars
and we'll pray
ask God for whatever we want you know
but I was like that seems to be more for
us like we picked the songs we ask for
what we want
but I said this is something you're
doing for God like this it's
really impressed me
um you know and
it was funny uh we were going through
the buffet right after they prayed to
get the food and the guy who was
throwing the dinner he came over to me
and he like he grabbed me and he was
telling the server he's like give him a
lot of food this guy wants to be Muslim
and I was like you know my wife I was
like just polite but I was like what is
he talking about I don't want to be
Muslim I don't want to be you know any
kind of religion or whatever you know
like I've already figured everything out
I thought you know I make my own
religion
and uh I sit down to eat and the young
guy the teenager he asked me he said so
what is your religion you know you're
not Muslim because he knew because I you
know I talked to him about it and I said
oh I kind of just look at all the
religions and then I pick whatever I
want you know I just kind of put things
together myself
and then I was thinking like at that
moment like it hit me I said
like I left
Christianity I was frustrated because
it's man-made
and I said and I'm doing the exact same
thing like how hypocritical am I that
I'm like making up my own thing
you know and I said maybe I need to
reevaluate things
so after that experience you know I go
back to the Muslims at college and I
started telling them you know I really
like you guys believe this I really like
you know I start asking them questions
like I did my grandma
like start grilling them like what about
this what about this
and they said you know they said we
don't know our religion like we should
we admitted they said but
all you got to do is go get the Quran
and read it it'll tell you everything
it'll explain everything to you
but I was like
that's what I wanted to hear about the
Bible you know when I asked my
grandmother let me just get the Bible
it's like no you know confusion but they
said no just go get the book it's from
God it'll explain everything so I went
out I bought the Oxford translation of
the Quran I started reading it
um
I got to in a week I got to Adam Ron in
Translation right
and I was convinced I said this is what
I've been looking for like this book
this is my Creator talking to me
you know and and something really struck
me like I get to I always remember this
verse is so so like in sort of you get
to like the 130s like 135
it says in there
Allah says like it translates like be
Jews or Christians and you'll be guided
is to say no we follow the faith of
Abraham
right he's on the truth
and he was not one of the polytheists
and I read that and I was like
think about like I wanted to be like
Abraham like I wanted to live like Aaron
when I read about him in Genesis I like
I wanted his way of life and this book
is telling me this is his way of life
like my father this is this is what
you're looking for right here
so I said I gotta be whatever this
religion is I don't care Whoever has
this book this Quran I gotta be it
and I went back to the Muslims and I I
it was Ramadan was coming so I said I
want to fast with you guys
you know so I tried faster with him I
don't think I was doing it right like I
didn't know the fifth I was still like
eating until sun rises all the way you
know I'm not you know I didn't I'm a I
think I'm drinking water you know I
didn't know you just don't eat or
something uh so you know but I was
driving and you know I was fasting with
him and they said why don't you come to
the mosque and break your fast like come
have you started with us so I said okay
you know I'll I'll do that you know I've
been there once before so and this is
like a year later because I went the
first time I must o5 and this was 06 so
Ramadan
and so I went to the mosque and I could
pass maybe for like uh somebody from
Hashem like maybe you know people think
like I'm maybe Lebanese or something so
when I went there nobody knew I was a
Muslim they just kind of gave me food
they sent salon to me I'm like yeah and
I don't stay back you know and and I sit
down and I'm eating kind of by myself
and you know I see people around me and
I just kind of follow what everybody's
doing
and then um one of the people from
college one of them is like she was a
good friend of my wife uh she had her
dad come talk to me and so her daddy
he's come and talked to me and he said
um I think you know my kid from college
and he's like what do you know about
Islam so tell him he's like I like your
beliefs I I believe there's only one God
Only God should be worshiped I like your
beliefs about prophets about Jesus and
so he's like come with me to the office
I was like okay so we go to the the
office and they brought like their Board
of administration like their President
right and he comes in he says what do
you know about Islam and I said I love
it I I I like your beliefs I like the
fasting that makes sense to me I was
like I I agree with all all the
teachings I said I I understand like you
know everything you guys are teaching
it's in the Bible too
and he's like so you want to be Muslim
and I was like yes and I'm like whoa
what did I just say like it just
came out like my heart spoke for me you
know and then they got excited and they
got me like a gift bag and I'm like okay
what am I getting myself into you know
and he was like you know
he's like you know we just want to make
sure he's like we're gonna have you go
out and do a testimony of Faith you know
shahada and he said you're gonna say
that nothing worthy of worship but Allah
and you're going to say that Mohammad is
the message of Allah
you know at the time I didn't know
hardly anything about Muhammad
right because they don't teach us about
it he's like they just skip over him
though he's had like the biggest impact
on human history since he was became a
prophet
nobody teaches us about him
but I said to myself I believe no
problem
and I said if Muhammad
got this book this Quran he has to be a
messenger of God so I said I have no
problem accepting that even if I don't
know anything else about it I just knew
if he got this book it's Quran he's the
messenger of God no other explanation
for him
and so they took me out I did my shahada
and it was Ramadan like Friday night
Ramadan there's like 700 people in the
mosque you know we're in Kansas here but
we we still get pretty good Muslim
population there uh and so I have all of
these you know I did my shahada I don't
you know all these people come up and
hugging me give me their phone number I
never had so many dudes hug me in my
life you know and uh it's just like go I
know I I prayed I shot I just followed
along you showed me how to make wulu I
prayed in a shot I don't know what I'm
doing I didn't stay for totally because
I don't know what's going on you know
and so I'm driving home I hate to spin
and I'm just like wow what is what is
what did I do like just I'm like full of
you know endorphins and adrenaline and
there's no much going on so I went home
and I woke up in the morning I go out my
family's eating my breakfast
and I told them hey guys
I am now Muslim
and they're like
okay neat like we don't like we don't
know what that means but like okay you
know so I was like I don't know what to
say okay they're like whatever makes you
happy you know that's fine to go uh so
uh you know I I finished out Ramadan and
I started trying to attend some classes
and you know the first they put you in
like Arabic alphabet you know but
I know they always try to get Muslims to
be able to read the Quran but when
you're a new Muslim that is what you
need right now you don't need the
alphabet you need to know like Al Qaeda
you need to know what Muslims believe
you need to know how to practice
you know so they put you in the alphabet
class you know and I don't know what's
going on I'm trying to learn Arabic
um you know and
you don't really know people when you're
new and so like my first year as a
Muslim I had some poly off you know
because I had you have a lot of bad
habits to break that are not Islamic and
so that first year was bumpy for me you
know I started off good then I started
hanging out with my friends they start
pulling me back to old things
um start you start neglecting maybe
Salah or whatever or going out with them
again
um
but you know I had something holding me
I wasn't as bad as before you know like
totally you know but uh you kind of have
this right and so then I I had a rough
first year and then that second Ramadan
came
and I remember I went for taraweeh like
I said I was fast and Ramadan I'm trying
to do Ramadan I stopped going out with
him on Ramadan and I go to tarawee and I
just broke down like first night of
totally and I was like crying and I'm
thinking to myself I said you know I
believe this wholeheartedly like no
doubt I need to go all in like I have to
you know I have to quit being fake with
myself I have to quit lying to myself
you know so I said
I gotta do this you know I'm all in so I
I went in I was like after that I
started getting really serious about
Islam and I started after that I started
I stopped hanging out with my old
buddies except like maybe go to dinner
or whatever but that kind of died out
because I couldn't go with them do all
the social things they want to do I
started going through them like I joined
the tafsir class and I I was since I had
the biblical background and I was always
reading the Quran again
um I did well like with the you know the
the chef he would give us like a test or
something like he saw I have some
potential so he started taking me under
his wing like hey Michael come over here
let me let me go over stuff with you let
me let me teach you stuff
and so I got really serious about
learning yeah yeah you know and and um
then they start putting me like to do
like help out with dollar because
they're like okay you know about
Christianity you know and uh they had
this we had a guy here in Kansas named
Dr Dirks Gerald Dirks he's written a lot
of really good uh books about Islamic
Christianity he has a book called The
Cross and the Crescent he passed away a
couple years back but uh and uh you know
he came and did a seminar for our mosque
and he taught us you know kind of like
dollar tips and how to give dawa and I
was thinking like you in that moment I
said you know I have a responsibility
because these are my people I know their
background and I'm learning Islam right
now so I feel like I need to get on
board with this you know doing dollar
calling people which means I need to
study more you know and all that so
that's I uh
I started to get really involved after
that so I was going through the computer
class I started joining the dollar
committee and going to those meetings
and it was really good for me you know I
started watching after I do that so you
get all those uh devastated arguments
and and because we're Kansas we used to
get a lot of missionaries come to the
mosque all the time to practice on us
and they would come in and they would
just act like they're here to visit or
they would act like we there you know
they want to know how to make friends or
whatever with Muslims and just you know
but then they would you know try to say
like do you know the injeel we can show
you the injeel you know no I know what
you're talking about you don't have the
NGO you know so you know we'd have those
discussions and so I I got pretty good
at arguing with missionaries and so then
it became like the chef would seek me on
them like when they come to visit he's
like I'm Michael you go see those guys
Michael go go talk about those guys you
know so
um that kind of helped build my my at
least my debating skills but also it was
important in Dallas that we try to do it
like the prophetic model right so I'm
actually coming at it with concern for
other people and wanting the people to
see the truth not just bash what they
have you know and make them feel like
they give up you know like I won that's
not the goal the goal is that I show
them the beauty of what we have and so
that they're you know called to it and
want to become Muslim you know so that
was kind of my journey and then from
there I just stayed active and then
eventually you know I also I was a
teacher that's my profession before now
I'm an Islamic school principal but
um I felt too with that ability to teach
I had a I had a duty to teach people in
Islam too so I started doing Youth and
the chef put me to do the youth classes
and so I started working with youth
which made me force me to gain my
knowledge fast
because uh not that I'm you know not
that I'm all great at knowledge or
whatever but you know when you have to
teach people and they come at you with
questions
that makes you spend your free time
researchers instead of watching movies
you know or whatever so so that was a
good motivator they just knew what he
was doing with me
myself
so that's my story already I think
that's phenomenal bro and I want to know
what the other brothers think I could
literally see Angelo's face light up too
because he was Christian too or Catholic
right so I I think like when his face
was lighting up at times I think there
were like parallels that he can compare
from his own life
yeah yeah no it was reminding me of the
time when I was going to do the
uh
what's the thing called I completely
forgot the
but the baptism man I was uh with my ex
my ex-fiancee and then as soon as we got
in there I've told this story many times
so like if people watching this they've
been watching they know but brother I
was there and then the guy was like okay
repeat after me
Jesus Is God stop for Allah and as soon
as they said that I was like
God is God
and then uh the the person that was like
holding on to me they looked at me and
then they they didn't want to put me in
the water but like they put me in the
water yeah and they held me under the
water for at least like five ten seconds
oh and like I knew that I was like no
these other people like they only put
them in for like one second like I've
been down here for like five ten seconds
like they're trying to hold me down here
for a second and it was just it was
crazy but like nah you're telling me the
your story man it's all linking for me
yeah
it was interesting when I became
I became scared to tell them because I
thought you know they asked me when they
interview me they're like are you a
Christian at that time was basically a
deist but I had been Methodist so I said
well I was Methodist so I just kind of
went with that you know get the job you
know and uh
then I became Muslim like that October I
was like I didn't want to tell them
because oh they're going to fire me
because they were pretty strict about it
um but you know all the time I'm working
there
through like they kept giving
no I kept getting signs that I'm oh
there we go there we go oh the correct
path like they made their teachers study
church history
you know as I go to church history they
talk about like well you know Jesus
taught you know James and the Jerusalem
Church then Paul came along and he
wanted to change the religion modified
for the the Gentiles and I'm like so I'm
hearing this I I've secretly I've become
Muslim or whatever you know and and I'm
hearing these things and they're
teaching me but it's reinforcing my
Islam and my decision because they're
telling me this history like okay well
Paul you know he wanted to adapt it for
the Greeks and the Romans so he made
modifications to it and adjusted it so
that it would be more palatable to them
you know and so like subhanallah like
they're reinforcing it and even they
would say
they talked about Prophet Muhammad he's
a big part of church history so the
church has to try to they say okay he's
a prophet but then you say okay if he's
the prophet of God like he's the last
prophet you got to get on board then so
what they do to get around it they say
well God felt bad for the Arab people so
he sent them guidance he sent them
Muhammad but he's just for them we
already had Jesus over here and we're
good to go you know and I just said like
what man you all don't even understand
the the situation you don't understand
like you're still on the from the Jews
the idea of God just picking ethnic
groups to give guidance and and that
kind of a thing and I said this is from
our food it has to be Universal anything
else does not work anything else does
not make sense so
it was crazy I remember I had a dream
even I I had because you know I I'm
getting into this you know these these
things you know I don't Christians like
to say they have a dream and that's how
they get guided that's like the dream
comes after I'm already confirmed right
I already know but
and this to me I also put a lot of
pressure on me to take this serious so I
became Muslim October
all right in the first two months I was
into it right still reading the Quran
and I hadn't gotten you know my fallen
off a little bit but that December comes
and you're getting bombarded with
Christianity in December right because
it's Christmas time so that they're
going to extra masses I gotta go sit
there and monitor the kids while they're
at mass and they're just hitting you
with it it's on TV all the time you know
everything so I'm going to wonder and
I'm like
I know I'm like if I did the right thing
or not so I said I'm pretty I'm sure so
I make the I really do I said Allah I I
know I think I'm I'm doing the right
thing you know just make it clear to me
make me for sure clear so I know I'm
doing the right thing
I go to sleep
and I'm dreaming and in the dream I have
water like coming up on me like I'm on
the earth you know and it's flooding and
it keeps coming up higher coming up
higher coming up higher it's like up to
my neck to the water
and I see a boat coming
and on the boat is like four guys from
the mission
and they grab me and they pull me out of
the water and sit here on the boat and
I'm like safe now so I woke up right
after they're like boom woke up so then
I was like okay like I don't know what
else you are so this is what I asked for
like show me for real like if I'm doing
the right thing and it's like you know
this is showing like Islam is saving me
from drowning and been doing your
drowning me drowning and being misguided
you know it's like but you know I don't
I didn't base everything on the dream
the dream comes after I've already
convinced by the Quran it's just this
was from Allah maybe alhamdulillah Mercy
to keep me on the path when I'm starting
to waver or have doubts you know but I
think that too to me that puts a lot of
responsibility on me like I have to not
just be a Muslim but I gotta help share
this Dean I got to help you know uh
promote this stuff so you know that's
why you know trying to do the things I
do online and teaching the community and
all that stuff I feel a lot of
responsibility like Allah has pulled me
out of the darkness into the light I
need to share this life you know with
everybody around me is whoever will
listen you know
yeah that's that sounds like the
Estacada for you
but I didn't know how to do it yeah
yeah but it's it's crazy that even like
even though you didn't know how to do it
you were so sincere that Allah answered
it anyways
but it makes you happy like I think you
think about the story with the kid uh
the kid with the monk right and he asked
the law he says he's going between back
and forth he says is the magician's way
right or is the Monk's way right and
these monks were talheed monks right
they're not they're teaching Talib you
know he says the prophet of Allah right
so he's like which one is right he asked
Allah he says oh and that Beast is
Terrorizer he says oh Allah if the
Monk's way is the truth is what you want
from me then let me kill this beast
that's terrorizing everybody right and
he throws that Pebble hits the Beast and
kills it right so he goes back and tells
the monks amongst his Allah has shown
you a great sign
now you have a big responsibility now
all right you've been you've been you
have a huge responsibility so I always
think about that with my dream I said it
was at the same level but still like
it's not a lot like I have a big
responsibility here when you're given
this you know you have to you have to do
something with it you know interesting
so before Romney asked a question I
wanted to ask you something brother yeah
when you decided to go all in with these
studies and everything and like really
really like do your part and actually be
Muslim actually learn more about Islam
and everything
uh what did it for you like in terms of
like keeping you on track with
everything because like a lot of people
you know we we tend to fall off we tend
to have those moments where we have high
Iman then we have low Iman
and then sometimes we're motivated
sometimes we're not motivated
um sometimes life gets busy sometimes it
doesn't get busy like what what allowed
you to keep at it
alhamdulillah really a lot you know
guiding me but I think certain things
like having a mentor like the chef
taking me under his wing was a big big
help for me because he's giving me stuff
to research or he's given me books to
read like you know I would ask him
something he's like you know what read
the he had his bookshelf here but here
go you need to read this and then we can
talk about it so having that Mentor
person it was a big help
um and
also in like I think putting you know
being honest with myself all you know
and restricting
you know like kind of cutting out a lot
of the distractions uh before I was
Muslim I was so into music and movies
like I have like I have this huge CD
collection and all this stuff and I
started to replace that stuff
so instead of listening to the music CDs
I start getting like lecture CDs right
so I I'll be listening to you know some
lesson uh like uh you know like stories
of the prophets or something like that I
would listen to that while I'm driving
around instead of the other stuff
instead of watching movies you know I'd
get on the dean show because we didn't
have you know when I become Muslim 06
YouTube was mostly like silly stuff so I
would go like the video show and I would
be watching that in my free time you
know so kind of uh removing those things
you know like uh
for your garden to grow so you got to
remove the junk and you gotta plant the
good stuff if you just do one or the
other it's not going to work
um so I think doing that but of course I
do still have ups and downs I am a human
you know you have times where you might
burn out I was talking to uh yeah before
we started you know and you'll have
these burnout moments where
especially when you're giving a lot I've
given I've given I'm giving if I don't
refill my tank
I'm just stuck you know with nothing you
start getting like kind of like you know
you're like almost getting cynical or
whatever it gets kind of so uh burnout
or whatever you start being like grouchy
you know I start making a step you know
you start doing more attacking other
religion instead of doing something
beneficial and guiding you know and so
uh having some opportunities to take
some time out and recharge
um is essential I think um
so you have mentioned mentors uh do you
feel like you've had multiple mentors
throughout your journey or has it only
been like that one shave I had two real
ones like Dr Dirks as well the the
author but he wasn't regular and then uh
have a lot uh fellow preserving he was
more regular because he was there at the
mosque
um I would go to him I would spend my
weekends at them at the Masjid part of
it like I would go there he would make
me do the youth class then I would hang
out with him balance ideas off him ask
him questions uh you know he would give
me support
um and then also it helps to
um my wife is a very good Muslim so
having a partner in life that is
serious about the dean now she's not one
to go study heavily or anything like me
you know we're different personalities
in that way but
anything I bring around knowledge she
comprehends it she pushes me like you
need to be consistent you need to
practice it she's very practical so she
gives me for being too theoretical with
my knowledge you know so having a really
good partner uh is another thing that
helps you a lot she'll catch me she's
like you look like you're burning out
like I heard your videos on Tick Tock
lately you've been real you know
whatever you need to take it you know
get some recharge and you know or you've
been you've been uh you know you're
watching too many movies with the kids
but you're not you're not refilling your
your tank you know you know that kind of
stuff so having a really good partner uh
helped out a lot too you know I got
married I was Muslim four years before I
got married so you know I had the mentor
and then I got good spouse and then
keeping the mentor there uh for a while
now sadly he moved to Dallas in covid
you know the Masjid good layoffs and
they you know trying to marginalize him
like come with a you know put him to the
side gun I think because they're like
well we have to shut down we can't you
know do have a chance now and so he he
got a better job at Dallas and now he's
there
of losing that Mentor I'm not emailing
him here and there I've you know called
him or fixed them once in a while but
it's you know when you had somebody
right there it's it's different but uh
you know and people are now are asking
me to Mentor them like the youth and
stuff come to me and I'm like I feel
like you know I don't know you know uh
I'm still one of Mentor you know but
that's how we work you know you have
these generations and you have somebody
above you you need somebody above you
and then you can feed the people below
you you know
it reminds me of in martial arts we're
supposed to uh when we're training we
have to have partners that are
um not as good as us that are at the
same level as us and that are better
than us that we can be learning in all
different levels
yeah definitely yeah yeah
but Romney go ahead bro what are your
thoughts bro even muted talk so much
I uh my first question is actually how
is what was your grandma's reaction like
what did she say
so I well I tell you about like my
grandma the the religious one right she
always didn't like to think deep on that
stuff because honestly I'll be honest
um Christianity doesn't hold up to close
scrutiny right
it's a lot of feel-good kind of slogans
Jesus Loves You Jesus died for you for
God so loved the world they gave us only
begotten said it's a lot of this kind of
slogan kind of thing but it doesn't hold
up to close scrutiny so she doesn't like
to think about those things so I when I
got really into it
her thing was to ask my dad about it you
know because I would talk to my dad I
try to give him Dallas you know um you
know for my family being so secular
they see Islam as a lot of work
they just don't have it in them to
understand like religion is you have to
do something like I thought it's just
God is your you know you have a love of
God and that's all you do and it's
spiritual right but it's like they see
me practicing these things and having
these rules and they're not ready to
maybe take on that responsibility you
know so my grandma would ask my dad if
my dad would give her the arguments I
gave and they would they didn't know
what to say you know he would be like
yeah Michael says why does God have a
human set like why is he having a kid
like what is the reason of that what is
the point that doesn't even like what is
that you know they're like okay let's
not talk anymore about it
you know
you know her her Bible study group was
doing learning about other religions and
they were doing Islam and so she was
interviewing my dad trying to get stuff
for her class and he's like why don't
you just ask Michael and she's like no
no no no no uh we don't want to we don't
want to get into that you know and and
then about my other side the my mom's
side too I was very close to them very
closely still but they also when I first
got serious they were kind of worried
about me they tried to have like an
intervention they're like okay you go to
the mosque every day
you're fasting Like Mondays and
Thursdays sometimes like what is this
like you're doing all this stuff we
don't understand you know and
I just basically said I said you know
you guys believe there's God right and
they're like yeah
I said so if you believe there's a God
there's anything other than devoting
your life to God makes sense
psychologically
is there any other way in life if you
know there's a God and you have to go
back to him
and they just got quiet they're like
yeah that makes sense left me alone you
know okay do what you want you know do
it makes you happy you know and I need
invite them to the Moscow I remember it
was a compliment I took it as a
compliment but
they came to the mosque we had like
alkiga when I had uh my son and we had
the dinner at the gym at the mosque you
know and they came in they watched this
make Salah and then my grandpa said he's
like
you know what your religion reminds me
of I was like what he's like it reminds
me of the Ten Commandments movie like
you guys are like Moses you know so I
think that as a that's a good compliment
you know but uh you know he just felt
like he's like you know it's not it's
very Noble and I can't get a lot of
respect for it you know but they don't
you know still like you know in American
culture you can have these taboo you
don't talk religion you know too much
you got to be really close to somebody
to talk to you I said don't talk
politics don't talk religion so you know
when we get into it if it gets heavy
somebody brings up the football game you
know somebody brings up change the
subject you know uh they're like he's
getting too heavy they're starting to
sweat I make him think about Judgment
Day you know they're like okay uh how
about how's work going you know you know
they don't want to to keep talking about
those heavy topics because you're you
know if your heart
you'll feel it you know you say okay I
should be thinking about this stuff but
I don't like it you know it's
responsibility you know
it's heavy
yes sir man that just shows the state
that the West is in where it's like our
minds just it wants to throw this
blanket over reality and everybody's
just delusional bro everybody is just
living in this fake World in The Matrix
in the Dunya well and then when you
start bringing the truth though they
start sweating it's like nah brother I
don't actually want to talk about that I
said come on man how do you not want to
talk about the actual reality
yeah
I remember one of the when I used to do
the Catholic school they Christianity
has good stuff in it too like because
it's some stuff from Aisa right but it's
a lot of stuff from other people but
it's once in a while they got Nuggets
that are really good and they have a
long history they've reflected on this
stuff you know and I remember one of the
priests said something but I said this
is true
you know for Muslims too he said that
everybody is like you have a hole in
their heart that only God can feel
but they try to fill that hole of
everything else other than God and then
they're never satisfied
and I said you know even you know he
said the truth even though you know that
oh I'm the truth he had some truth in
that you know I said that's that's how
it is everybody they know they're
missing something when they don't have
connection to Allah when they don't have
practices like we have
they feel that emptiness and they fill
it with everything else you can fill it
with even me I remember
before I even
I was really into martial arts this will
be my purpose in life to be martial arts
master and pass it on and you know I
blew my knee out playing basketball with
my cousin
and I couldn't do martial arts for a
long time and I you know that was a
shattering moment for me because I lost
my purpose so I said okay if there's
something that could hold me back from
my purpose this can't be my purpose as a
human being if there's something
physical that can hold me back this
cannot be what I'm made for
so um
bro that
man that reminds me man like these
brothers here no because like before
before Islam I was actually I had found
my purpose my purpose was like gonna be
professional fighting and I was like
training like all the time and then
became Muslim and then my first Ramadan
was coming up and I was like you know
what it's my first time being Muslim I
don't think I'm gonna do Ramadan because
I want to be able to Train full time
because I got to be on point for for
these fights and all that stuff and then
it's like Allah said all right bro say
less say less and within like two days I
got this groin injury and bro wallahi
for over a year I have not been able to
train martial arts the way that I was
before and I had the same like
mind-shattering experience where I'm
just like oh like my purpose like what
am I gonna do now like yes I'm a Muslim
but like my purpose my purpose was to do
professional fighting and then it's like
I realized like damn like
that that can't be the purpose yeah
if we don't wake up on our own then
Allah will wake us up sometimes and
that's good for us and that's you know a
lot one thing good for us but when Allah
wakes you up sometimes it's rough
that's what you need like you're not
waking up on your own you know somebody
can't wake up you dump water on them
right it's rough you gotta wake them up
you know so sometimes
you know but uh sometimes if we wait for
a lot of wake us up so don't miss a
rougher but it's good for us if we get
the sign you know if we get the link We
ignore that that's not good
man
it reminds me of the story my dad used
to tell me as a little kid
he and it's in Spanish that I heard it
so I might translate it not so good
um and the story goes like this right
there's this guy and there's a flood
happening
so he he runs up to the top of his house
to the Rooftop
and um as the flood's getting higher
there's this like rescue boat that's
coming in like picking people up and
then he's like they're like yo yo come
on man come on like we gotta go like
there's a flood happening like we don't
know if you're gonna be saved if you
stay up here he's like no no I pray to
God God's Gonna help me and they're like
ah okay cool cool so they left second
boat comes and they're like yo yo yo
this is the second round like we we
don't know if we're going to be able to
have anyone else come at you he's like
no no I pray to God God's Gonna Save Me
like everything's all right and they're
like okay cool third boat comes like yo
this is the last round like if you don't
come with us like No One's Gonna Come
Back to save you and the water was
already like almost at his neck and he's
like no no I pray to God everything's
gonna be good
so like all right okay cool so he ends
up drowning and then he ends up like
going the gun he's like God like I pray
to you to to save me from the flood why
didn't you save me he's like bro I sent
you three boats yeah
I don't remember that bro I remember
that
I love that little thief right Allah has
that kindness but also it's subtle so
like when you use when he gets out of
jail Allah didn't send some lightning
bolt and split the gel open and bust him
out you know some crazy way right he has
the guy tell the king I know somebody
that can interpret your dream so they're
real subtle they go Yusuf says okay but
I want my name cleared before I get out
Ali salaam so get it you know he does it
they get it cleared and he comes out
it's very subtle the way Allah works
with us but he gives you clear science
you just gotta read them you know it's
their point you know so I know this was
the atheist though I was like I want to
see God in front of my face you know
like let's just say man Israel said the
same thing you see what happened to them
right you know so you can't it's not on
our terms and that's the thing with
other religions
they teach you everything is on
everything God is doing just for you God
is doing this for you definitely in
Islam Allah does so much for us
but you forget who's the master and
who's the servant when you study those
other ways of life they make it like God
is doing everything for you he's your
genie you call on him when you have a
wish you you you call for him when you
need this and he did this for you and he
did this for it's like you have to do
stuff for Allah Allah gives gives you
things but he's not going to do it for
you you have to make that decision you
have to to make your choice you have to
commit you know do those things it's
Gotta a lot well definitely I suppose to
understand when if you go to Allah
walking Allah comes to you rushing right
but
you've got to do those steps right you
got to do that walk you know so
people forget that you get it twisted
that's why you produce I mean those
religions produce this secularism this
atheism too because those people they
didn't get there do I answered one time
so they throw everything out the window
you know even I you know
I watched that Thor movie the the new
one right
the whole thing is this guy he's going
to kill all the gods because he didn't
get his prayer answered right but it's
like this is like atheist propaganda
yeah you don't catch it but people don't
get it it's subtle but this is atheist
propaganda they're looking they're
saying look these Gods Are Gonna Let You
Down they're all they're not real
basically they're trying to tell you
that or they're not worth worshiping or
worth your time be your human live your
best life or whatever right this is
atheist propaganda yeah
you know you know when I watch those
stuff I watch it but I'm like I'm
looking for stuff you know I make a
connection and stuff like that you know
but uh but you know that kind of idea
that well God didn't do things how I
want it so I'm not gonna believe it what
kind of arrogance is this man
I noticed that like a lot of the things
in the movie and film industry today is
atheist propaganda or polytheist
propaganda the gods it's always Gods
it's ever God you know what I mean oh
yeah oh yeah it's subtle it's subtle but
it's to a trained eye you know we notice
these things but most people just goes
over their heads and just subconsciously
they accept it you know but they're not
even aware that this is what they're
feeding into
you know yeah and I mean when they
they have the other propaganda too for
everything major sins and those kind of
things yeah yeah
um
where they try to just portray one guy
they kind of just butcher it
but did you call my name and call me bro
do you wanna do you wanna anything else
you wanna ask him uh brother Michael
before we wrap up
I I didn't have a question but I did
have uh something kind of popped up in
my head when he was talking
um about basically people living like
the secular society
it reminded me of a conversation out of
my Freddie recently he was telling me
that um you know if you do the math if
you like fully transform five people to
fully accept this to them give it out
they're full on doubt carriers and then
they each basically bring five more
people you're at 25 now after a year or
two years right and then they all those
25 bring five people and that goes on
and on after like 11 years that would
have been the whole world
now obviously theoretically that sounds
beautiful
but why isn't that the case and
obviously they're the people that are
just not going to accept it but I think
there's another level nowadays where it
comes to people basically it comes to
people's desires
they are so almost comfortable in their
life with their their wealth and their
their just you know their comfy chairs
they're just chilling sitting eating
McDonald's every day whatever they feel
good and
when you come to them
and kind of break up their reality in a
way where it's like well you you can't
sit for seven hours straight on your
couch playing games and watching movies
you actually have to get up to pray
you know they're like something in their
head they're like I don't want that even
if it'll logically makes sense they
emotionally don't want to get up and do
that work so I think that's a big part
and that's why you I think you're
talking about Michael that's a big part
when it comes to people and their
acceptance or not like if you look at
the elites of quraish one of the big
reasons they didn't want to accept
basically to get rid of their idols and
stuff is it brought money in it brought
Traction in Mecca was like the place to
go worship why those people used to do
basically Hajj
so they were making money so if they
denounce that then there goes their
comfort there goes their basically
elitism and all that stuff that's why a
lot of the the youth and the poor who
don't have this super comfortable life
or someone who's close to their you know
being intact they're like yes this is
beautiful this is what I need and it's
only Allah who can really strip somebody
up there basically Comfort
um in a way that would bring them to the
truth
right and you even have really good
Muslims that they get that Comfort to
where they're not active struggling for
the dean so they be Muslim maybe they
either do their past a lot inshallah
right but they do theirs a lot and they
go watch their their news and they go to
work and they go home and they just did
they said you could imagine like if the
sahaba did Islam like that they pray
their Salah and they go to work and they
go home and they do that like Islam
would have never made it out of Arabia
you know yeah
and so we have a we have this
responsibility especially Muslims in the
west like we have a bigger
responsibility because
nobody knows about it here you know I
mean something that's better than even
when I was younger but there are huge
gaps still between you know for people
knowing about Islam like they should or
even you know we also when you raise
kids in that environment if you're not
able to transfer your dean
we lost them oh no I think sometimes it
happens bro when the when the guests we
have on they get a call on their phone
oh yeah that's true you know but it
should be should be good by now
there we go
Michael welcome back bro oh sorry I
don't know where I left off but
even when we raise the kids here there's
no safety net like if you don't transfer
your Dean there's no you know especially
if we don't have strong communities uh
um even overseas now when I hear from my
my co-workers or they say even back home
the safety net is is dwindling because
they've been so influenced by by this
modern uh you know culture or whatever
but uh you know everybody's like they
always have anything like uh one dollar
group they say each one's each one you
know like everybody has like you said
everybody needs to be responsible enough
to pass on even the problem said that
right he said convey from me even if
it's a single item right because you
might give it to somebody and then they
take it and run with it or expand on it
and and so on even you know like the
Muslims that I knew in college may Allah
bless them nothing against them at all
but
I would say I'm definitely more active
than they were and they are right
I wouldn't have been Muslim if I didn't
meet them and have good interaction with
them so child they're sharing maybe in
the good I do but
you know
they're they're you know the people
aren't always gonna you know jump on it
and take off with it but you know that
kind of a thing where
uh we need more people to be active you
know in this Society
so like you guys are doing something
good with this podcast whether you
realize it or not this kind of stuff
where you're you're spreading this to
more people and reaching more people and
you even the youth I told some of the
the youth in our community I'm going to
be on the three most of the like that's
my favorite podcast that's crazy you're
going to be on there you know but it's
like you're reaching people and
sometimes they don't want to hear it
from somebody
you know middle I'm 40 now alhamdulillah
before they used to listen to me better
you know something about that as that
age Gap gets bigger than you lose some
credibility with them on some level they
say you don't understand us anymore you
know when I was in my 20s they're they
listen to everything I say you know
now I'm like their dad's age they're
like oh you know bro that's I want to
say that before we wrap up this is so
weird because even like a few years ago
for me I would lose that relatability
once they were like a little bit older
than me you know what I mean now I I
seek more wisdom and knowledge from
those that are a little bit older than
me when I talk to you when I talk to
brother Gabriel you know I don't I don't
see them as just because they're older
you know they they're out of touch with
you know the Dunya and the things that
the fitna the men our age are going
through young men you know I see him
more as like let me like pick out your
brain you know and like save a lot of
wasted time in yours you know right they
say what they say though the the wise
person learns from the mistakes of
others and the fool doesn't even learn
from their own you know so that's what
you do you know you take from those
who've already gone before you and
that's that's the way having those
mentors right
hi boys
unfortunately do have to end a year
which is actually I don't know why the
whole comment section was debating on
whether music's Haram or not I don't
know why
we're sitting here talking about how
Muslims should carry now and they're in
the comments like bickering with each
other Rolly relax
but you know
guys
links links in the description for all
of brother Michael's links Insha'Allah
um go on his platforms and inshallah
will bring them back in the future
with that being said Allah